Batman and a Disney plush show
Peacemaker himself popping up keep
watching to find out about all the
connections between Marvel and DC shown
in the mcu's most recent special
presentation James Gunn has the
distinction of having probably the most
experience dabbling in both the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and the DC Universe
he has written and directed all the
Guardians of the Galaxy projects in the
MCU including the Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special and the upcoming
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3. he's
also the brains behind the Seconds Of
The Suicide Squad film and created and
directed The Peacemaker series on HBO
Max now James Gunn and Peter saffron
will lead the redubbed DC Universe which
according to deadline makes gun
exclusive and means that the Guardians
of the Galaxy holiday special and
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 will be
his final projects for Marvel despite
the perceived rivalry between Marvel and
DC mcuzar Kevin feige has offered
nothing but support regarding guns
promotion to head of the DC Universe
feige told The Hollywood Reporter how he
will have any time to work on DC until
May I don't know but once he does have
the time I'll be very excited I'll be
first in line with the Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special being Gunn's
penultimate project within the MCU it
seems only fitting that the special will
be loaded with possibly the most DC
Easter eggs in the history of the MCU
since gum was only tapped to lead the DC
Universe in late October it's unlikely
that any of these Easter eggs are meant
as intentional references to his rise to
his new position at DC but there's
certainly some funny coincidences one of
the most striking references to Marvel's
Chief competitor DC comes after Drax and
mantis succeeding kidnapping Kevin Bacon
only to realize he's not the hero they
thought he was but merely an actor who
plays heroic characters bacon realizing
that his characters are disappointed
puts on a British accent and pretends to
be a World War II fighter pilot
Manchester says he uses his own voice at
which point he strains he chooses to put
on the Persona of a character that bacon
has never played before announcing quote
hello I'm the Batman hello I'm Bruce
Wayne like many directors James Gunn
does like to reuse the same actors that
he's used before since he has good
reason to trust them again in the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
actor tanashe kajese makes a small Cameo
as officer Fitzgibbon called Jesse
previously played Argus agent and
Suicide Squad support staffer Flo
Crawley in guns a Suicide Squad
similarly German comedian flular Borg
has a cameo in the special as a
bartender Borg also played Javelin a
member of the doomed first wave of
cannon fodder characters in The Suicide
Squad additionally after drag semantis
are given a copy of the map to the Stars
which lists the addresses of several
celebrities and animation shows them
going to these celebrities homes on the
map the celebrities shown include the
suicide squad Stars Margot Robbie and
John John Cena the latter of whom
starred in Peacemaker but for all the DC
Easter eggs in the special there are
almost as many Disney and Marvel Easter
eggs to be caught but typically in one
scene the scene with Drax and mantis
visiting Hollywood Boulevard gives the
most obvious callbacks to other Marvel
and Disney properties one of these is an
actor appearing as a look-alike of
Johnny Depp from Disney's Pirates of the
Caribbean franchise a reference that's a
little surprising given the recent
controversy regarding Deb and his
ex-wife Amber Heard in the scene the two
Guardians also see several impersonators
of other characters from the MCU
including someone wearing an Ant-Man
mask an actor dressed as Black Widow
another dress has Captain Marvel and
another actor dressed as Captain America
particularly the Steve Rogers version of
the character this Falls mantis into
thinking that she's seeing the real
Steve Rogers after taking pictures with
Drax and mantis a Taurus family thinks
they've just taken photos with the God
of War it's unclear who they were
referring to although Scandinavia facts
multiple gods of War and Norse mythology
including Odin a character who appears
in the MCU play by Anthony Hopkins
however it's quite possible the family
confused drugs for the popular video
game character Kratos who is also known
as the God of War Drax proceeds to beat
up an actor dressed as gobart and while
GoBots are not Marvel or Disney
properties the costume does look vaguely
similar to The Iron Man Mark 1 suit from
the first Iron Man movie
[Music]